dancing with the stars gank your
bachelor fans how hardcore Oh I'm beyond
ha hot cold like I'd heart be saved at
this point I mean we're married so she
makes me watch good husband good husband
we're big fans in January 6 cannot come
soon enough
we're all waiting to see if Paulette
Piet finds his co-pilot but maybe the
most excited of all Pete's parents how
do you bring girls home if you live at
home what happened oh no I am very lucky
I'm very lucky so I'm very supportive
they are and I I've brought girls home
and it's not weird in the next morning
I'll wake up from the girls downstairs
making breakfast with my mom and they're
chatting it up and that's just the way
it's been does that mean if you get
engaged is the lady moving in we've seen
firsthand how supportive Peter's parents
are remember how they cheered during the
infamous windmill confession actually
yes that happened and now only we were
with pilot Pete as he gave his parents a
tour of the bachelor mansion just hours
before the limos full of ladies rolled
up I'm in love are you nervous yeah but
they're good nerves you know fun fact
Peter grew up just five minutes from the
mansion and as a senior in high school
back in 2009 he used to try to sneak in
during filming and his parents have
tried to last season when he was out in
the Bachelorette we kind of sneak away
to tried to see this family has strong
traditions to mark their Cuban and
German heritage you never break today
sure Peters dad also named Peter is also
a pilot his mom Barbara was a flight
attendant that's how they met number one
turn on kissing my ear red flag
someone's it's too loud
yeah we would not have worked out well
in true bachelor tradition expect plenty
of drama this season for one thing we
know Peters ex Hannah beef shows up you
know I was with Chris Harrison and he
said that your appearance on Petes
season he said it's big there is some
serious chemistry between the two that's
just undeniable and that's why we wanted
to have her back on the show what does
he mean about this Hannah I don't know I
guess we'll have to see in the meantime
this year's Mirrorball winner is gearing
up for the Dancing with the Stars live
tour kicking off in January she'll be
performing in the show at Radio City
Music Hall really at one stop why only
one stop you know my life has
drastically changed and so I'm just
trying to sort out what time I have when
I'm busy when I'm not what's what's
coming up in this next year so we'll see
[Music]
there are three married couples on this
tour but life on the road isn't all that
romantic especially when it comes to the
bunk beds on the tour bus oh yeah I mean
when I tell you that they're like this
big it's really hard and it's sweaty
imagine we're like upset I mean you know
we have arguments sometimes I'll be like
like go to your bunk bed so how do these
dance pros unwind in between shows the
boys are really into ping-pong player
glad that you did not say yeah but you
knew that I said I thought I was a great
tip I ordered a table tennis tennis
table that's coming like in two days
lucky were married see we can't even
sleep in the same bunk because I have
the dog and she's teaching my feet and
we so we just like hold hands
a little rough for you Sasha on the butt
but you guys are also headed to paradise
yes we are may 29 2014 2 para dice you
can go to D do with es a bluntest can't
for more information
[Music]